né à limoges le 25 février 1841 pierre
auguste renoir débute sa vie artistique
à 14 ans à paris il entre ensuite à
l'école des beaux-arts et devient membre
à part entière du groupe impressionniste
ses parents déménagent ensuite dans les
yvelines le département s'appelait à
l'époque seine et oise
ils vivent notamment rue de voisins à
louveciennes cesson nie toute la vallée
de la seine a été pour lui un vrai lieu
de création d'imagination et puis je
dirais de vécu dans sa bougival la
grenouillère à croissy sur seine ou
encore le célèbre déjeuner des canotiers
à chatou les paysages de la vallée de la
seine ont inspiré l'artiste renoir qui à
son tour a inspiré le département des
yvelines à l'occasion du centenaire de
sa disparition
nous sommes en train de développer sur
la scène toute une énergie de
déploiement touristique puisque nous
avons un potentiel véritablement accès
aujourd'hui sur des grands peintres
impressionnistes pierre auguste renoir
s'étend le 3 décembre 1919 à cagnes sur
mer laissant derrière lui plus de 4000
tableau